foreign
Chicago where Robert joins us Robert
you're on the Ramsey Show
hi Ken hi Robert hey what's going on
hey uh I'm in big financial trouble
where we owe over a million dollars all
in together including mortgage and
uh yeah
let's break it down
462 is the mortgage uh 96 000
student loan
uh February 2000 car is that Student
Loan Federal
no no it's with Ernest I've been paying
it back for a couple of years at this
point
okay how much was the car
and the car is 42 and the car the car is
going I already decided that okay good
we're going
to get rid of it probably was ten
thousand to twelve thousand dollars on
it but it is what it is that's fine uh
still going down the rest is the rest is
installment and credit cards and uh
our income is wait hold on a second 42
000 in the mortgage 96 000 in private
student loans 42 000 is the car
run run the rest because there's still a
good deal left is it all credit cards
what is it uh installments installment
loans and credit cards like private
loans so so give me the numbers uh yes I
I do have um 50 000 like a solar panel
loan as well solar panels uh what else
what's in the credit cards what's in the
personal loans
personal loans everything together is
approximately 225
000.
yeah who do you owe that to what what
persons well all of your favorite so far
so far
um live stream and upstart then so
and then there's some some credit cards
in there too so so here is here is
here's the thing we I've been trying to
be smart and didn't quite work out I was
in a position where I could lend money
to all guys who need it and you know
make profit on it so I would throw money
on
a card or you get the installment long
and then they pay me back and this has
been making some profit on it
so you're taking out the debt for other
folks right now one guy stopped paying
uh and it's it's really it's so much
stress I'm I'm done with it how much
money do you make
uh I would make 20 to 30 000 a year not
after all the costs did you say you make
twenty to thirty thousand dollars a year
yes and then that's after after all the
costs well my friends
from the from the you know
income
the income is uh about ten thousand a
month no what is your is that your
personal take home in your salary your
job is ten thousand lives ten thousand a
month okay it's like ninety eight
hundred oh my gosh you were in no
position to be taking out loans
for other people
yeah
um yeah I could spend a lot of time
telling you the Ridiculousness of all I
mean it's it's it's one thing to take
out debt for yourself it's another thing
to take out debt like some kind of a
lone shark and loan it to other people
you know that I think that you feel the
weight of that I think you know I hope
that you know
I I do oh I think that you do okay
um is it just you do you have a family
tell me more no
it's full family my wife she's sitting
right next to me here kids uh we have
three kids okay
um all right so here's we have a full
house are you both working
uh yes she's working her hours are a
little bit irregular so and does that
10K involve what she's bringing in
yes okay I need her to work 40 hours a
week
not irregular I need her to pick up
something that is just as solid as what
you're doing and then after she does
that and this applies to you too you're
both getting side jobs you guys are
about to work
your booties off
you have to there's no other way okay so
you already said that you're getting rid
of the car you're gonna take a 10K loss
that's fine you're still getting out of
32 000 of debt that's great solar panels
how is this is there any way to get out
of it uh are you able to sell them have
you looked into anything they
essentially replace my
utility bill that's what it is right but
can you get out of them can you sell
them
uh probably at a loss well we're getting
out of debt so it would be 10 to 15 000
loss if not more yeah but you're also
you're not thinking about the debt
that's gone so getting that down to
fifteen thousand dollars that you owe is
better than 50 000 right yeah just
getting rid of the car and the solar
panels if you can do it it's going to
give you some more room
to be able to start really going after
these other things
here is really the question I'm calling
with oh it's I I honestly we would need
to increase our income by about five
thousand a month yep
so what's your question and we're
honestly if I will float them uh credit
cards will store soon start charging
because the balances are like on zero
balance promotion and so on yeah
so I I'm expecting to get a bigger
payouts next year in August September
for what
it's it's money that's sold to me no
we're not waiting till August it's great
that you have money coming but we can't
wait or depend on that as the solution
because as you've seen before sometimes
folks don't pay so we've got to start
today what's your uh what are you paying
every month for your home
it's about thirty two hundred dollars
that's includes mortgage taxes Insurance
okay I
10K a month are you guys on a budget I
need to know how far how deeply you've
gotten into this we started to budget
where really caught our spending
significantly and we're
we have a buses ready for September okay
I need it down to here's the thing
there's no breathing room here we gotta
go and we gotta go like our life depends
on it because yours really does
wife is working we're starting that
process to get her full-time tomorrow
okay you guys pick up side hustles I
don't care what it is any money right
now is going to be so helpful for you
I'm looking at ways to get rid of the
car instantly sell off these solar
panels if you can instantly I'm looking
for ways to
do anything I can I'm looking at your
mortgage to be honest with you and I
want to know what it when did you get
this house did you get it recently or
have you had it for a while two years
ago two years ago what's it worth and
what's the interest on it
probably it's under three percent
and what's it worth
600s we could probably walk away with
how much Equity do you have 650 and gets
so 120 130 000 equity in it how much 120
or 30.
120 30 we put 20 dollars
my friend I would be scorched Earth now
I I I would if it were me I'd be selling
the house and we would be getting a
place that is the kids are kids they'll
be fine I'd put them all in one room I
would be going bananas on this to take
that 130 put it towards this debt get
you some Breathing Room your life is
going to be so much better so much
faster this house is just as big a
problem in my mind as everything else
it's too much of their income it all it
all is I'd get out of it now that's
that's what I would do I had rent yeah
it you need every dime that you can get
and all I'm not gonna make any bones
about all of it's gonna suck
it it's not gonna be fun oh his life
sucks already yeah but I'm just saying
like you know this is going to be the
one of those Seasons where it's like wow
you're gonna feel the gravity of the
decisions that you made but the good
news is you can course correct and you
can write this ship and you can make it
happen and you're gonna make it happen
but you're it's not gonna happen if you
don't do the things that Ken and I told
you today starting today don't leave
anything out don't try to skirt the
process do it hang on the line Robert I
want to do a couple things Austin for
Robert so Robert hang on the line number
one I want to get you in Ramsay's number
one Flagship product Financial Peace
University we're going to give you every
dollar as well the number one budgeting
tool in the world and I'm gonna set you
up with a one session with one of our
financial coaches yes this is the Ramsey
Show hang on the line